my most
rabid fan base by far over all these
years has been my like my
kid films my spy kids audience these
kids
watch those movies over and over because
they're they're
action films made for for children and
families in particular
at a time when they need empowerment and
netflix had come to me because the
spy kid movies had just done so well in
their services could you make us a a
series of films
that do that and i said i'd love to i
you know it was hard to make them for
the theater because
kids couldn't just drive themselves to
the theater or watch it a thousand times
they'd have the parents have would have
to take them but on netflix they could
just sit there you know i don't
i don't have to sit there and watch
glitter force with my daughter she can
go click it as many times as she wants
that's why those
they get such high numbers on those
types of films so i said yeah i would
love to because my kids are now at the
age where they can make
the films alongside me and so we came up
with this uh
team of students like an avengers
superhero team but they all have kids
and the kids
uh have powers but they don't know how
to use them because they're just so
young
and it's uh it's really fun i never it
was the most challenging movie i had
done
because as any director would know the
most challenging scene to do is like a
dinner scene where you got 11 people
well the whole movie i had 11 superhero
kids in every shot
trying to figure out how to film that
was incredible it's really
challenging and exciting and and i
already shot it and was editing it
when this happened and i'm scoring right
now that's why i
had a limited time today we're scoring
in vienna
and i'm remotely listening over here in
the other room
and uh i can't be in the orchestra room
like like usual
but they're all sitting like six feet
apart in vienna it's a wild time
but yeah a huge cast pedro pascal place
would like d'antonio banderas type
role uh boyd holberg branded a huge cast
even shark boy and lava girl even show
up as
superhero parents who now have a
daughter who's got shark and lava
powers and she's like six and they're
all doing amazing martial arts
what's crazy is they came in so trained
already a lot of them had already had
training
to do amazing stunts and action
and and martial arts that you wouldn't
expect from nine ten year olds it's
pretty
pretty pretty fun movie so i can't wait
for that to come out it's coming out
soon on netflix